good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight joe biden went to
pittsburgh today maybe you saw it he
announced his administration has decided
to
guarantee economy destroying crippling
hyperinflation
by funding yet another multi-trillion
dollar spending bill
biden claimed this batch of newly
printed money will go to quote
infrastructure infrastructure you're
thinking sparkling new bridges and roads
and airports
that's funny no it doesn't mean that
biden has a different kind of quote
infrastructure in mind
the kind that will definitely not
improve your life we're taking a close
look at that plan tonight and we will
have details for you
tomorrow but first tonight what if your
next door neighbor suddenly went
dangerously insane and started holding
people hostage in his house
would you consider that threatening
would you even notice it
those are not theoretical questions
something very much like that just
happened in our national neighborhood
canada the landmass directly to our
north our single largest trading partner
the country with whom we share the
longest international border in the
world
canada took a dramatic move toward
legitimately dangerous authoritarianism
in canada yes here's just one measure of
it
on monday the country's prime minister
justin trudeau outlined his government's
new corona regulations
canadians hoping to return to their
country must be tested before
and after takeoff he said quote if your
test results come back
positive you'll need to immediately
quarantine in
designated government facilities this is
not
optional designated government
facilities now when this happens in
other countries and it does
we call those facilities internment
camps
but because this is canada we're talking
about a place we assume is
passive and polite and anglo to the
point of parity
no one thinks to use that term in fact
no one thinks about it at all
trudeau's internment policy has been in
place since last month
and as far as we can tell no major u.s
network has even mentioned it
and neither has our state department
which ordinarily seems to exist to make
unhappy noises about human rights
violations around the world
but not a word about canada
preconceptions may play
some role here we assume that in turning
people is what russia does
boring people is what canada does
but not anymore suddenly canada is a
flagrant
violator of the most basic human rights
fail a covid test and they will lock you
up without trial
and go ahead and try to disobey
according to the canadian government
anyone who attempts to
avoid these rules detention in a
government internment facility for
example
could face a million dollar fine and
three years in prison
this is justin trudeau's canada
it's funny trudeau always seemed like a
cheerful idiot wearing weird costumes
and yammering on about diversity
who knew he was mussolini there might be
a lesson here for
other nations that are led by shallow
neo-liberal empty suits
know any underneath all the chirpy
identity politics talk it's not a joke
it's internment cells in canada where
everything has a euphemism those cells
are referred to as
approved quarantine hotels what are they
like
well as noted they're internment cells
what do you think they're like
there are shortages of food and water
you could be sexually assaulted
as you're held in one listen to a member
of the canadian parliament explain what
they're like
the liberals instituted a federal hotel
quarantine requirement for those
entering canada
we have heard reports that is taking
hours to get through to book these
hotels dietary restrictions are not
being met
and food and water is not always readily
available
that's in addition to this program
continuing after reports of sexual
assault
this is mind-boggling
oh the liberals did this it's not very
liberal to intern
people is it according to a report in
the post-millennial the doors
in many of the internment facilities
don't lock detainees have no way to
protect themselves
while they sleep hence the sexual
assault they also don't have access to
adequate medical care
in one case canadian authorities
detained a man with diabetes called
ray truesdale what was true dale's
criminal was flying from tennessee to
toronto on a business trip
as he waited in confinement for his
corona test results his jailers forgot
to feed truesdale for more than 24 hours
ultimately truesdale left his cell and
went downstairs in search of something
to eat
and there he found others who were being
held without food they were screaming he
said
in the end canadian authorities informed
truesdale that his coronavirus sample
had been damaged somehow
so he had to remain in internment
or consider mitch bolu a canadian who
landed in calgary after a business trip
to florida
he told canadian television the
experience was very much like a
kidnapping
he was put quote in a black van with
tinted windows and taken to an
undisclosed location
where am i going he asked why am i going
there the response
will tell you everything when you get
there he thought it was a prank he
thought it had to be but it wasn't a
prank
quote i got out there and there was
plastic all over people walking around
in hazmat suits
it was like jail pretty much yeah just
don't call it jail
and that's an order directly from
canadian state media
this fall the cbc canadian state media
ran a story with this headline
prime minister health officials warn
canadians against
believing covid19 internment camps
disinformation
warn them against believing sound
familiar that claim that conspiracies
theory said cbc that the federal
government is preparing to forcibly
intern canadians is patently false
the cbc assured canadians the government
was preparing quote
voluntary quarantine sites yeah
voluntary in the sense of being
mandatory
which is what they are they're mandatory
and by the way as a matter of science
how does
packing infected people into crowded
internment facilities
reduce the spread of the coronavirus
that's a good question and some have
asked the canadian government that very
question
but they haven't explained we do know
and this is significant that canada has
fallen far behind
other advanced nations in distributing
the vaccine which is interesting given
the decades of propaganda all of us here
have been subjected to
about the glories of the canadian
healthcare system according to andrea
taylor who researches this at duke
canada quote had more faith in the
global supply chain
than other countries oh they believed it
worked
the globalism thing that turned out to
be a big mistake but rather than admit
that globalist stupidity
is why they can't get vaccines to their
population justin trudeau has decided to
punish his own
citizens it's his fault and the
population gets punished
do you recognize that impulses look
familiar to you it should because
neo-liberalism is always the same no
matter where you find it
what's so interesting is that canada's
new rules apply only to covid patients
other transmissible diseases are exempt
people with aids aren't being sent to
internment facilities thank god
no one's tried that since fidel castro
did it in the 1980s drug-resistant
tuberculosis is fine too that's a real
problem but
not in canada only covet
a disease with a 98 survival rate
weirdly too and you may recognize this
as well at the same moment they're
clamping down on travel by their own
citizens the canadian government has
announced plans to admit
400 000 new permanent residents from
other countries over the next
eight months and by the way that number
will increase substantially over the
next couple of years
none of those people those immigrants
from the third world will be forcibly
quarantined in canada we're not calling
for them
to be but it's interesting the
difference they won't be arrested
in fact they'll be rewarded because
they're not citizens only the citizens
are punished
back in november justin trudeau admitted
what's going on here
it's not about coronavirus stopping the
virus saving lives no
this pandemic he said is an opportunity
to permanently change
western civilization this pandemic has
provided an
opportunity for a reset this is our
chance to accelerate our pre-pandemic
efforts
to reimagine economic systems that
actually address global challenges like
extreme poverty
inequality and climate change
the great reset and we don't want to
give justin trudeau too much credit he
may be sinister but he's not smart it's
not like he thought that phrase up
no he took it from his role models in
this country
at a forum hosted by the world economic
forum in mid-november john kerry our new
climate czar
laid it out yes he said the great reset
will happen and i think it will happen
with greater speed and with greater
intensity than a lot of people might
imagine
in effect the citizens of the united
states have just done a great
reset we've done a great reset and it
was a record level of voting
we're at the dawn of an extremely
exciting time
has it been extremely exciting for you
has it been extremely exciting for most
americans
as the people in charge mismanaged this
country all the way to the brink no it
probably hasn't been it's been a sad
time for most people
but for power mad leaders hoping to
eliminate centuries of constitutional
restraints on their own ambitions
it is indeed an exciting time
could what is happening in canada happen
here that's the question that's the
whole point of this segment
you might not think so we don't need
internment cells here because unlike
canada
we have the vaccine and we're
distributing it to tens of millions of
people and once you're vaccinated
you can live normally that's the whole
point of getting vaccinated
but then you wonder if that's true why
are joe biden and kamala harris still
wearing their silly little
obedience masks everywhere they go
they've been vaccinated
so is everyone around them so why the
masks
why the restrictions what exactly is
going on here we know it's not science
we know that for certain
according to the cdc once you are
vaccinated
of course you don't need a mask anymore
we can kind of almost see the end we're
we're vaccinating so very fast
our data from the cdcs today
um you know that that vaccinated people
do not
carry the virus don't get sick um and
that
it's not just in the clinical trials but
it's also in real world data
well we hope vaccinated people don't
carry the virus otherwise why are we
getting all these vaccines what's the
point
turns out the real world data confirms
common sense once you get the vaccine
you don't need a mask
that's a biden employee so why is
everyone still wearing it why are people
with vaccinations walking alone outside
with masks on why are joe biden and
kamala harris wearing masks
sincere question you'd think our media
would ask that once in a while
but they're not they're asking very
different questions in the other
direction in fact they're heckling
members of the opposition political
party people who've been
vaccinated and demanding that despite
the vaccination
they put their masks back on
uh yeah when i'm talking to the tv
camera i'm not gonna wear a mask and all
of us have been immunized
so does it make us feel better you're
welcome to
step away if you like
the whole point of a vaccine cdc
guidance
is what we're following
the whole point of the fantasy as if we
needed to be reminded we do
because we've lost sight of that that's
what the science says
but nobody cares what the science says
wear your obedience mask
immediately it would make us feel better
which is the passive-aggressive way of
saying do it or else
now watching that does make you wonder
how would our media react here in the
united states if dr fauci one day
reluctantly concluded that
actually we need coronavirus internment
facilities in this country obviously for
our safety
we don't want to violate anyone's rights
but we gotta have them
sorry how would our media respond
take a look at the clip we just played
again look it up on the internet
you see that reporter and you realize
that person
badly wants ted cruz tossed into the
back of a black van for coronavirus
non-compliance
hauled away and not just ted cruz but
you too in fact all the disobedient
politically
inconvenient people held without trial
on public health grounds of course
until they no longer pose a mortal
threat to the rest of us and by the rest
of us of course we mean
the good people the people who obey you
think that couldn't happen here why
because the constitution prohibits it
you think that couldn't happen in
america it just happened in canada